hey you guys flickers of fear time so
we're going post-apocalyptic
post-nuclear uh on this installment
ever since i talked about the british
post nuclear war movie threads from the
1980s uh which was on shutter i don't
know if it's on there anymore uh which
is probably one of the most depressing
films actually not even probably is
absolutely one of the most depressing
films i've ever seen one of the most
depressing films ever made uh a couple
of people in the comments
uh recommended that i talk about this
movie when the wind blows which also
came out in the 1980s so that had been
on my list because i heard about it when
i was researching threads this is
actually an animated film and it's
available on 2b if you'd like to watch
it for free at least in the united
states not sure where it is streaming in
other countries but yeah so this is a
little bit of a different take on like a
post-nuclear war type of uh situation
now uh i don't know like most of you
that uh are you know around here all the
time know that i actually grew up in the
1980s i was born in 1972 so i was
actually in junior high in high school
during the 1980s
and i remember as most 80s you know
people that had their formative years in
the 80s um remember
there was just this kind of palpable
sense that
nuclear war was probably like right
around the corner so a lot of
even a lot of kind of like pop music
from the time a lot of movies at the
time you had movies like war games that
came out in 1983 stuff like that
where
uh you know the possibility of a u.s
soviet nuclear war was a very very real
possibility in some schools including
ours uh you know we you do like the duck
and cover [ __ ] where you like put on
your desk and stuff like that as if that
would help but you know so it was
something that
a lot of us grew up with it being like a
real possibility so the 80s were like a
really really weird decade if you didn't
live through them um there's a lot of
things i like about it but there's a lot
of things i mean i wouldn't go back but
there were a lot of cool things about it
like entertainment wise but it was kind
of like a schizophrenic decade because i
do kind of feel like on the one hand
we're teetering on the brink of nuclear
annihilation and then on the other hand
we have lifestyles of the rich and
famous and like everything was like
super gold-plated and gilded and you
know super over-the-top glamour that
kind of stuff so it was just like a
really weird juxtaposition maybe those
two things are kind of related in some
ways just kind of like eat drink and be
merry for tomorrow we die type of
attitude i'm not really sure but uh you
know that's the subject for another day
but anyway
so
uh i think i mentioned when i talked
about threads
uh we also had in the us we had a
similar type of movie not quite as grim
as the british one obviously because the
british are really good at doing grimm
uh but ours was called the day after
which came out in 1983 it kind of had an
all-star cast which the threads one
didn't which i think made it scarier
that was actually the day after was
actually a tv movie
and i remember everybody talking about
83 i think i was in
fifth grade something like that um maybe
sixth grade i can't really remember 83 i
would have been 11. so yeah i guess that
was like fourth or fifth grade but i
remember everybody talking about it the
next day like oh my god
we're gonna get bombed by the russians
and it's like all this like devastation
and [ __ ] like that and it was like a big
deal so everybody like talked about it
and from what i know of the uk and
people i know from the uk they said they
had absolutely the same thing happened
uh with threads which is actually like i
said a lot more realistic and it was
basically made
as a warning you know what i mean like
this is what it would actually be like
you know according to what we know so
let's not do this okay so the uh so
there's a bit of a lesser known uh entry
in the whole british post-nuclear media
subgenre if you want to call it that
this is an animated film as i mentioned
this came out in 1986 called when the
wind blows now this was actually based
on a 1982 graphic novel
by raymond briggs if that name sounds
familiar it's because he had also
written the children's picture book
which came out 1978 called the snowman
and that was also turned into an
animated film uh much later i think that
82 83 i want to say but yeah uh so that
came out and i've seen that one as well
i think david bowie did music david
bowie actually did the uh theme song for
this movie as well uh and this is the
same animation team as the snowman so
even though they did slightly different
techniques on this one which i'll get
into in a minute the characters are
animated very very similar
so the appearance of this movie it's
really interesting i don't really think
i've seen anything done quite in this
way before as i said the character
drawings designs are very hand-drawn
they're very cuddly and adorable just
kind of like the characters uh in the
snowman where it's just kind of like
these little heads and these kind of
like big chubby bodies and like i said
it's very hand-drawn very sketchy kind
of looking
but then the backgrounds and most of
this takes place in a single cottage so
the backgrounds are like stop motion
type things so they're like actually 3d
environments so like stuff is made out
of clay and like other materials and
then these animated characters kind of
like move through them
so that's kind of like the main bulk of
the animation and then
in between there are these more kind of
like really beautiful sort of like more
sketchy watercolory looking or colored
pencil kind of looking sequences which
usually represent kind of like
flashbacks or fantasies that one of the
characters is having like there's one
with like butterflies and spring and all
this other kind of stuff and they also
use this similar style uh as a contrast
like once the nuclear annihilation
starts to happen and they use this kind
of sketchy animation to
show basically the destruction of great
britain so it's like a really
interesting like juxtaposition
now as i said this is a cartoon but uh
unlike the snowman which i think i
remember that being a little bit
depressing too but this one
probably not for kids um
and especially nowadays because i kind
of feel like
kids might like it but i don't know if
they would get it's very adult themed in
the sense that it's almost like a black
comedy which i'll get into it a little
bit i don't want to go too far in that
direction but it does have like a lot of
black humor to it
but i don't know if kids nowadays that
didn't grow up with this whole threat of
nuclear annihilation and knowing all the
stuff that we knew about back then like
what nuclear war would be like like what
the aftermath would be like which all of
us did know back then um i don't know if
they would get a lot of it but you know
i don't really know because you know i'm
not a kid so i can't really tell but i
don't know if i'd really want to show
kids this it's a little bit upsetting
you know what i mean uh it's kind of
like sad but i will say if you're like a
big fan of sort of like depressing
animated movies that are kind of set
during wartime or talk about wartime
atrocities like grave of the fireflies
or something like that um then this will
probably be right up your alley i think
grave of the fireflies is more
depressing than this this is depressing
in a different way uh which i'll get
into i'm trying to like articulate how
this this is more like a heartbreaking
or like a tragedy type of story with
like some black humor to it but those
two things like work in concert to like
give it its tone
um i will say that i think that
what makes this story so much more
affecting
is that it is laser focused on just two
characters and you only see
the nuclear annihilation in sort of like
these sketchy other animated
sequences so
a lot of the destruction is kind of i
don't want to say it's like left to the
imagination because they do show some
sequences of it but
it's not
you know i kind of feel like threads was
more like we followed a handful of
characters and they showed like a lot of
the destruction like in real time like
real life this one is kind of more
focused on these two characters and like
how they deal with the aftermath and
with them like not really knowing what's
going on in the wider world and they're
sort of cluelessness about it is what
kind of makes it sadder at least to me
so as i said this starts out with kind
of a weird like out of context sequence
there's just like some actual real news
footage or you know of russian tanks or
whatever and then you have the title
song which is by david bowie i will say
too that i think roger waters did like a
lot of music for this um you know just
that he did the score i believe and
there were also there was a soundtrack
and it also had some songs by like hugh
cornwall from the stranglers and like
some other people on it but i don't
remember there being other than the
david bowie song at the beginning and
other than the roger water song at the
end like over the end credits mostly
it's just like a score in between i
don't remember like a lot of
kind of pop song type stuff in there at
least as far as where lyrics and stuff
go
so after that sequence then we're
introduced to one of our main characters
now the main character uh this little
guy is named james blog or sometimes jim
now he we started out he's uh at the
library and he's reading the papers and
he's kind of like tut-tutting about oh
international tensions and their
heightening and all this other kind of
stuff and he's getting kind of worried
about it um so then like he takes the
bus home this is they don't specify
exactly where his where his house is
like where this cottage is but it's
somewhere in sussex and it's like really
really remote they seem to like not
really have any neighbors close enough
by that would come to check on them
although it does seem like they're
within like a bus ride of town because
he's you know at the library at the
beginning and takes the bus home
so he goes home and there we meet his
little wife uh hilda who's like a little
little plump you know kind of
uh stereotypical
british housewife of the of that
generation i suppose
so the blogs are kind of like
they're sort of i don't want to say
elderly because they're not ancient but
they're like retired retirement age so
i'm assuming like 60s
and they sort of are meant to represent
sort of like the everyman type of
typical
british older couple
of that generation the ones who had
lived through world war ii
uh you know lived through the blitz
lived through all of that and had this
sort of like keep calm and carry on type
of energy like stiff upper lip type of
you know we beat the nazis blah blah
blah um not in an overtly
uh
they're not obnoxious about it but
they're just like very well we're the
british and we will sort it all out you
know everything will be we'll straight
we'll get it all straightened out type
of thing
now james actually is kind of worried
enough about this whole because he's
been hearing about all these
international tensions so while he was
at the library he got these little
booklets you know like uh what was that
called survive and
i can't remember what it was called
survive and do something
or
i don't know i don't remember what it
was but it was an actual thing that they
had that the british government put out
so he gets like a couple of little uh
pamphlets and he takes those home and he
starts talking to hilda he's like you
know i've been hearing all this stuff
and maybe we should like you know read
this pamphlet and do some of the [ __ ]
they say in here because who knows like
the worst could happen
hilda is just kind of like ah [ __ ] man
you know that's never gonna happen and
they're always yakking and it's like
it's she's more worried about she's like
i don't even read all those newspapers
all those stupid politics it doesn't
mean anything and she just wants to read
the stars column which i guess is like
celebrity gossip or something like that
so she's just kind of he's talking about
like international politics and she's
like uh you want sausages or you want
mashed potatoes or chips or what you
know what i mean she's like making his
lunch but these two i really like these
two characters because as sort of like
daughtering and
like naive as they are
you know everybody i kind of feel like
more
in the the uk than in the us but
everybody kind of knew that you know
believer grandparents or they knew
somebody that was like this they're
actually kind of sweet characters
they're sort of like not
really all that informed about things
they just have this very very quiet
little isolated life and they read the
news but it's like a lot of times like
james doesn't really like understand it
or is just kind of going off of like
half remember type of stuff but he does
seem to like take the [ __ ] seriously
now they're listening to the radio while
they're eating and there's a report on
the radio that says um there could be
actually a soviet missile strike in the
uk like in the next two or three days so
james is like okay well we better do
what this booklet says because the
government no always knows better knows
best and this is what they say to do is
we're gonna follow these directions to
the letter
so uh basically what one of the things
and this is a real thing because this
was an actual uh booklet that they put
out
and uh so they're like well he prized
most of the doors off of the cottage and
he builds this sort of like like a lean
to like he leans him like up against the
wall like in the living room and sort of
nails them down so they don't move so
you know it's like kind of like a
lean-to torch type of shelter and then
like stacks up like cushions and
suitcases and stuff like that like in
front of it so to sort of shield you
from a blast or something like that so
he does that um he kind of starts
painting the windows white like the
glass windows and uh you know starts
filling up any bottles they can find
with water and stuff like that so he's
kind of getting ready just like the
booklet says and it's funny because
hilda doesn't like stop him but she kind
of like
she's kind of like following him around
sort of like hey don't get paint on
those curtains or i hope you don't mess
up my wallpaper and it's always so she's
like very very worried about
you know her house like messing up her
house
you know more than she doesn't really
think that i guess she doesn't really
think it's gonna happen she doesn't
really take it uh really seriously at
that point like james calls their son i
guess at one point you never see him
pretty much these are the only two
characters that you see through the
whole movie but uh they have a son who i
think his name is also jim and he has a
wife and baby and he lives some distance
away presumably so james calls him and
says hey you know they said that maybe
there will there will be a nuclear
strike so i gave you that pamphlet so
are you gonna like do the stuff that it
says and like you can hear jim like
laughing over the phone like whatever
this is you know if they bomb london
we're all going out together so i guess
he lives in london uh so yeah so he's
just like not taking it seriously at all
he's like yeah whatever what are you
gonna do well which is probably true i
mean
because the stuff i mean that's kind of
one of the funny things about this movie
you know in a very grim grim sort of way
is that the stuff that's in this booklet
none of it i mean most of it probably
would not help you obviously uh in the
actual event of a nuclear uh holocaust
but
i guess it was just
and and this movie kind of like subtly
has this theme to it is that it was just
something to like make you feel like you
could do something like you had some
control over the situation even though
you obviously absolutely do not um but
yeah so i think it was just kind of like
a thing to make people feel better like
they were like taking some action even
though it obviously wouldn't uh do any
good
so uh so yeah so during this part yeah
this is the part that's funny this is
like the first half hour of the movie is
basically james going around the house
trying to do like everything that this
booklet says to do uh you know making
the shelter and painting the windows and
all this other kind of stuff um and as i
said the humor is very evident because
obviously all this stuff in this is not
gonna do jack [ __ ] like if you actually
get hit by a nuclear missile you're just
gonna be vaporized as it was like not
gonna matter it's like i said it's just
like hiding under your [ __ ] desk but
the thing that's also kind of like funny
but also like in a grim like black humor
kind of way is that
james and hilda are still thinking about
and maybe this is why they don't really
think of it as that big a deal because
they're still they lived through world
war ii so they remembered the rationing
they remembered the bombing they
remembered uh the blackouts they
remembered all that stuff and so they
were like well you know we lived through
that and we're fine um you know it was
hard but it wasn't that bad like you
know we got everything back up to normal
like after not too long so they think
this is gonna be the same they're still
looking at things from a world war two
perspective not really
you know not really twigging on to like
the much larger thing that like a
nuclear war is a completely different
thing even though james does seem to say
oh this is completely different but he
doesn't really seem to grasp the
enormity of it and he's a little bit
it's kind of funny because he seems like
he wants to keep up with stuff and he
does keep up with stuff but he remembers
stuff wrong or he keeps kind of like
casting back to like world war ii and
how things were back then because that
was what he had experience of he doesn't
really know like what the [ __ ] is going
on nowadays he doesn't really know who's
running russia he doesn't really know
you know he's it's everything is like
half remembered but he's walking around
almost like
authori i don't want to say
authoritative because like i said he's
not being obnoxious or mansplaining or
anything like that but he's acting like
he kind of knows what he's talking about
and he obviously doesn't know what he's
talking about at all so it's just like a
really really sad yeah so it's the kind
of thing where
like i said after world war ii it's like
yes [ __ ] got bombed to [ __ ] and like
they had blackouts and rationing and
everything like that but it's like you
know after that everybody pulled
together you know we we put our
shoulders to the wheel and we stiffened
our upper lips and we you know got
everything back to normal you know what
i mean we we were having tea and having
[ __ ] breakfast telly and all this
other kind of stuff and everything was
fine we lived through it so this is just
going to be like that so we just have to
like wait a little while and everything
will get back to normal
so
the funniest part to me this i had to go
back and like write this down like what
he said exactly because this part like
cracked me up so much
so
the the booklet says you need to have at
least two work two weeks worth of food
stored away which like i said it's
obviously not gonna help you
two weeks yeah everything will be back
to normal after a [ __ ] nuclear
missile strike after two weeks yeah
it'll be fine uh so he's like okay well
we need two weeks worth of food at which
point hilda is like oh i better leave a
note for the milkman to like leave us
however many pints like of milk or
whatever and i'm just like okay and then
he's like well i'm gonna go down to the
shops and get some bread like 14 days
worth of bread and so he goes down there
and when he comes back he says oh they
were all out of bread and then he's like
seems surprised by that he's like oh
must be just panic buying that's all it
is everybody's panic buying he's like
but here's what i got here's their two
weeks rations and this is what he says
exactly like i said i had to go back and
write it down because i thought it was
so funny uh two packets of ginger key
brings it in our tray two packets of
ginger creams half a jam sponge a tin of
pineapple chunks and a tin of christmas
pud and i was just like thought that was
so [ __ ] funny that's what they're
gonna eat for two weeks
it's the [ __ ] it was i love that it
wasn't even a whole cake it was like
just half cake i don't know why that
cracked me up so much but that was just
like the funniest thing yeah and then
they're saying stuffy like oh i should
have got peanut butter at the store
because that's the booklet says to get
peanut butter and she's like we don't
even like peanut butter like what the
[ __ ] the british people are not liking
peanut butter don't get me started on
that peanut butter is delicious but yeah
so the fact that these characters are so
lovable
but are so like clueless about what an
aftermath of an actual nuclear war would
be like
is kind of where a lot of the film's
like poignancy comes into play and why
it's like hilarious but it's also like
really really sad like at the same time
like hilda at one point says why don't
we just write a letter to you know bj
whatever his name is like mr russian
whatever it's david why don't we just
write a letter to them and say hey
please don't bomb us because we're
rather tired of being bombed it's like
that kind of stuff and that he's all
encouraging like oh that's good dear i
don't think the post will be running
though the post might be late at like
after bombs fall so they're just very
very like
it's just and i'm cracking up thinking
about it but it's also like really
really grim and depressing at the same
time so it's just kind of like the fact
that they just have this child-like
faith that after they get by a nuclear
bomb then you know order will be
restored and everything will be fine
like after two weeks or whatever and
it's just they seem to genuinely
genuinely believe that because like i
said they lived through world war ii and
it you know it took more than two weeks
obviously but they got through it you
know even though it was difficult for a
long time
so as i said that's the first half hour
of the film but so about half hour into
the movie obviously you knew this was
gonna happen because it's a post nuclear
war uh they are actually hit by a
nuclear missile they don't really say
where it hit you know enough where
there's like a big bright flash and [ __ ]
like that
uh the radio actually only gives them
three minutes warning
uh but both james and hilda managed to
get into
james's shelter which fair play to him
does work and like shielding them from
the blast their house is kind of all
[ __ ] up well i mean their house kind
of stands but all their windows blow out
so obviously everything is like [ __ ]
up inside so then you have one of those
uh sequences like i was talking about
earlier where they kind of show
devastation around the uk like just
buildings being [ __ ] blown away and
like a train being blown and like going
off a [ __ ] uh you know trestle or
overpass or whatever so it's just kind
of like
you don't know where that happens but
you're just kind of led to believe that
pretty much the whole entire uk has been
essentially destroyed
so after that sequence we go back to the
blog's cottage
now
as i said their house is kind of [ __ ]
up inside like the walls are still
standing but they survived without a
scratch because they were behind the
shelter which like i said it did work
the funny thing too is that james he
never calls it a shelter he never calls
it a lean-to he always calls it exactly
word for word what it calls it in the
book in the pamphlet which is inner core
or refuge so every time he says it he
always calls it the inner we have we
have to stay in the inner core refuge he
says uh yeah so he calls it that every
single time which also never failed to
crack me up
now he says that in the book they're
like obviously you made this shelter and
you have to have like all your [ __ ] in
there like your food and water and
everything like that because you're
supposed to stay in there
uh for two weeks because of the fallout
now hilda is just not having this
because she's like how am i supposed to
go to the toilet and you know he's like
well you just go in a bucket or so she's
like absolutely not i am not she's like
she's offended by the very suggestion so
she's like i'm getting out like i beat
the hit we beat hitler i'm not i didn't
beat hitler so i could like go like [ __ ]
in a bucket or whatever she doesn't say
that but you know what i mean uh you
know she's like i'm going upstairs to
the to the bathroom like a normal a
human being but they are in the shelter
for like a day or two i feel like and
then they kind of start getting bored
and like they start it's very very small
so and they're both in there and they're
kind of chunky so they're like you know
they're all
strained like they're all their joints
hurt because they're kind of crammed in
there together so after a day or two
she's like look i don't see any fallout
like she doesn't really understand the
concept of radiation or anything like
that she's like [ __ ] it i'm just going
so they both get out she's like i have
to start tidying up because she looks
out she's like oh look at the mess and
it's like you know my curtains and oh my
curse my cushions and all this other
kind of stuff so she wants to get out
and start cleaning up
and so basically they're only in there
for like a day or two and then they come
out because like you said she doesn't
see any fallout so how could anything
possibly be wrong
so the rest of the movie is essentially
this very very slow
grimly hilarious but also really
heartbreaking
chronicle of these two lovable old
people
slowly dying of radiation poisoning and
not knowing what it is every time one of
them develops a symptom like at first
they're just like oh i'm really tired i
don't feel that good and then hilda
starts kind of like throwing up but
everything is like written off james is
like oh well you're just nervous because
of the bombs but it's like it's all over
now you know the bombs have passed you
know we're still here you know the house
is a mess but we have insurance and we
can like get it cleaned up we can get
new curtains and stuff like that um you
know and then later on like her gums
start to bleed
and he's like oh that's just ill-fitting
dentures that'll that's all that is and
in the morning or once all this you know
blows over you can just go down to the
dentist and he'll fix you right up it's
just that kind of stuff i mean they
actually think you know she says she has
a headache and he's like oh well i'll
pop down to the chemist in the morning
and get you some like he really thinks
that anybody's still there now they
don't really seem to realize uh they
seem confused that there is no
electricity because they're like oh we
have to turn on the tv and see what
happened they try to call their son but
they'll obviously the phones are dead
and they don't understand why that is
you know why are all the radio stations
dead because they have like a
battery-powered radio you know why
haven't the newspaper and milk arrived
it's like you know obviously because of
the bombs maybe they'd be a little bit
late but they've always you know during
world war ii we always got the milk we
always got the newspaper you know it was
late sometimes but you know so it's that
like they go outside in the garden and
hilda says oh the road looks a bit
melted and he's like oh well perhaps
that's why the milk is late or something
like this the kind of tone that we're
going for they're like completely
completely [ __ ]
clueless about what has happened now
you're led to believe because it's the
focus is just on them
you don't actually know if everyone else
is dead you're led to assume that
everybody else or at least everyone else
around them is probably dead and they
just have like no idea because as i said
they think everything is just going to
go back to normal like immediately so
they sit out in the garden even though
obviously radiation fall out but they
don't see it you know and she even says
well what does fallout look like and
he's like oh i don't know snow i guess
except maybe grayer oh well i don't see
any of that so it must be fine it starts
to rain and they're like oh yay water
and they like start collecting water and
bowls and like they drink it obviously
it's like poison
you know so they knew a little bit like
they knew enough to like do the shelter
and everything like that but they didn't
know as much as they thought they did
and it kind of like ended up like
[ __ ] them up so as i said i don't
know if they realized that maybe
everybody else is dead or at least
everybody they knew is dead or
it could be that maybe they do know like
deep down but they're sort of like using
this misplaced optimism and denial and
this sort of like cheerful
everything will be all right sort of
like attitude to kind of like mask that
knowledge because they don't want to
deal with it it's really hard to tell
because they do really seem very very
clueless
so as i said as far as british
post-nuclear war films that sub-genre go
uh this one isn't as soul-crushing as
threads which as i said is one of the
most depressing films i've ever seen
and one of the scariest films i've ever
seen also
but it kind of has its own
sort of gentler
melancholy or like just kind of this way
it sort of works on you a little bit
because the story is so focused and so
intimate
you can imagine this is basically like
watching an animated version of what it
would be like to watch your
you know very lovable and endearing
grandparents but who are also really
clueless
succumbing to
radiation poisoning or like the effects
of a nuclear holocaust and uh it's about
as cheerful as that sounds you know and
it's just like the whole time they
actually think they're gonna get out of
this and they actually think there's
gonna be an after you know it's like oh
well the garden's all messed up oh well
after this all blows over
i'll go down to the hardware store or
whatever and get some potting soil and
we'll sort it all out everything will be
okay and they just keep saying that the
whole entire time until they [ __ ] die
look at the end so
yeah you really have to be in a mood to
watch this as i said it's not
it's it's not like watching threads in
the sense that you're just like oh my
god
that was the most horrible thing i've
ever seen because it does have
humor to it but the humor actually like
really highlights
the horror of it like really effectively
you know what i mean just because these
characters are so lovable
and but they're just so naive and
childlike that it's just terrible like
watching them and you know what's
happening to them and they don't know so
it's like really really sad so
i mean i wouldn't recommend this but
maybe
for if you want to be like a masochist
like maybe a fun double feature one
night
get yourself
some earl grey tea and get yourself some
digestive biscuits lay it all out on the
table
and watch this and threads like it's a
double feature
and then try not to and then try not to
feel like you want to kill yourself like
at the end of that please don't do that
seriously that would be really really
bad but yeah so as i said when the wind
blows it is on 2b at the moment uh at
least as of this recording and if you're
in the us uh for free i'm sure it's
probably streaming elsewhere it might be
easier to get in the uk i would imagine
but yeah if you're at all into like 80s
post-nuclear war type uh films then you
really should check this one out because
this one was actually weirdly
entertaining because like i said it's
it's grim but it also has like sort of
like a really [ __ ] up like black humor
to it and i kind of like that and so
yeah if you've seen this uh or if it
sounds interesting to you let me know in
the comments and that'll do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one bye